Incorrecto.
En esta sociedad multicultural e interseccional,
donde la mayoría nos reunimos y somos educados
por personas y con una etiqueta diferente a la nuestra,
donde no compartimos la etiqueta,
las normas tácitas son un problema,
donde las normas emergentes nos permiten conectar significativamente.
Son constituciones de un solo uso para un propósito específico.
Así que una cena de equipo,
donde se reúnen diferentes generaciones
y no comparten las mismas presunciones sobre cómo usar el teléfono:
quien mire primero su teléfono
se hace cargo de la cuenta
(Risas)
Inténtenlo.
(Aplausos)
Para un círculo de asesoramiento empresarial de extraños
en el que los anfitriones no quieren que solo escuchen
al capitalista de riesgo...
(Risas)
saben reír...
no puede poner de manifiesto a qué se dedican.
Para una cena con mamá,
donde quieren poner las normas
de lo que hablan las mujeres que también son madres cuando se reúnen,
si hablan de sus hijos, tienen que tomar un trago.
(Risas)
Esa es una auténtica cena.
Las normas son poderosas,
porque nos permiten cambiar temporalmente y armonizar nuestro comportamiento.
Y en sociedades diversas,
las normas emergentes llevan una fuerza especial.
Nos permiten reunirnos a través de la diferencia
conectar,
crear significados juntos
sin tener que ser lo mismo.
Cuando era una niña,
navegué entre dos mundos convirtiéndome en un camaleón.
Si alguien estornudaba en casa de mi madre,
yo decía: "Salud",
en la de mi padre: "Dios te bendiga".
Para protegerme, me escondí,
como muchos hacemos.
Y no fue hasta que crecí y a través del conflicto
que empecé a dejar de esconderme.
Y me di cuenta de que las reuniones para mí,
en su mejor momento,
nos permiten estar con otros,
ser vistos por quienes somos.
y ver.
La forma en que nos reunimos importa
porque la forma en que nos reunimos
es cómo vivimos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)